peace be with you
welcome to the Dee show internationally
viewed all over the globe and we talked
about that crucial question in one point
in your life you start thinking what's
the purpose of life you've been to all
the parties
you've imitated the movie stars you've
seen them on xanax - life's all the way
upside down and you start thinking man
why am I here why have I been created
and then you hear Islam hears
Christianity Jesus and you know that's
the conversation is that you got to
start having you got to start you know
learning about what would Jesus is
mission what was Muhammad's mission what
did these people call - and that's what
we were gonna be talking about today
when we talk about the purpose of life
and in the mix of it we have the author
John Fontaine who was a former Christian
started to really think he didn't want
to blindly follow his forefathers and
parents and he came to the conclusion
that Islam submission to the will of the
creator is indeed the truth because it's
based on evidence and proof it's a
believable simple message you can learn
a message that it contains that was
brought by all the messengers and this
book that he wrote fascinating
Jesus well if you didn't know you're
gonna learn it we love Jesus and the
message that we came with the injeel and
its original all of this and more here
in the d show don't go anywhere
this is the isn't Jesus the greeting of
peace yes right we can have all the
prophets and messengers they came with a
greeting assalamualaikum
please be with you you wrote a book
called Jesus and the injeel now there
some people are like what is a Muslim
and you know for those I don't know
right now you reading it on the green
screen is showing you what I must submit
some people get terrified they get
really scared they hear muslimah
snapshot ria and they just go berserk
they turn into the Judi show and they
start having love for a slaughter like
man these guys are ok people you know
they're great I think I want to be a
Muslim call right now if you've already
like don't waste a second call 1 800 662
help in to come and people been going to
parties because that's what it is you
know life's like work hard from from
from Monday to Friday and you got a
party and we talked about another show
before with you is how did you hear
before that you you went through that
life and I got played out didn't it Rick
Lee yeah just constantly chasing your
dreams chasing live chasing money and
you don't you know you're not happy you
can't buy happiness you can't buy
happiness and now people associate with
religion with being just weird and many
of the academics the thinking people
they're like as soon as you bring up
religion they think that something you
know weird is gonna be you know brought
to to them but it's Lamas nothing weird
and you realize that when you actually
you stopped believing in things that
were not believable Trinity and you
started believing something believable
yeah I mean a lot of the time you said
Islam is well religion in general is
seen as like
something that you know it can't be true
but in fact it's a logical explanation
why and how we're here you know it the
Quran tells us other tells in the car
honey he poses a question did you create
yourself did you come from nothing
you know logically nothing can come from
nothing nothing can grate yourself there
has to be a cause there has to be a
purpose you know and someone who doesn't
believe in a purpose that's it's not
believable no it doesn't make sense that
the that the creation is purposeless
exactly it doesn't make sense there has
to be a cause you know I always tell
people look around you everything from
this microphone test123 has a purpose
yes right that jacket you know
everything the buttons on a jacket
everything the keys in your pocket it
all has a purpose the purpose of life
which is to submit our will and submit
and worship the Creator now that's what
you talk about in your book Jesus in the
injeel so you were former christian yes
and at a young age you start us really
dwelling deep into christiana used to go
to the the church of england you were
attending all the bible studies classes
is that right yeah i was about this yeah
well I was brought up in the Church of
England Church and we I went to church I
was studying the Bible taking part in
the masses and also I used to play the
church organ so I was very active on
that side as well and I remember the
first memory I have of this was we was
asked to write a song about God and my
chorus was Jesus and God Jesus and God
okay and I remember the vicar coming
over grabbing the paper and scribbling
out on saying Jesus is God and this was
the first time that I began to actually
question Christianity before this I just
accepted everything and this was only I
must have been maybe eight and nine
years old very young but I was
questioning the the the I was
questioning the religion of Christianity
and then I you know I was constantly
questioning and trying to figure out
what the difference is between the
actual church doctrine and the Bible you
know what the Bible teaches and what
church doctrine is something often which
is quite different before we'd walk more
into that you were eight how about the
person as 80 the other person is
eighteen or twenty eight and you know
we're talking about Jesus Abraham
Mohammed aren't these the names the key
figures that we got to talk about if
we're going to ascertain what really the
truth is they're gonna be in the
equation you can't just make up your own
religion and just say okay you know I'm
gonna do my own thing and then present
this to the crater is it yeah the work
there's I mean if there is a you know we
come to the conclusion that there's a
crater the the way he has community
communicated with mankind is through
prophets and messengers you know
prophets such as Abraham Moses Jesus and
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon them all
and he has given them messages and we
know in the quran the allah tells us in
the Quran that he's given the the taurat
to Moses there's a ball to prophet David
the injeel which is a message given to
prophet Jesus peace be upon him and the
final revelation which is the Quran to
the whole of mankind which is the which
of the Quran given to Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon that's what we're gonna be
focusing today because you actually went
you accepted Islam and you're basically
from your Irish will English English
Irish one of one of my grandparents is
from Island yeah well I'm from England
Manchester England
yeah so they can't tell you like if you
go back to have you visited Ireland you
know I've been twice before they can't
tell you because like I go back home now
I mean or if you go Manchester I mean
your English you know because some
people think like okay do your Muslim
they say okay [ __ ] go back home where
are you like there's a particular
country where Muslims comfortable
Muslims are from all walks of life yeah
I mean this is the beautiful thing about
Islam when you travel the world the more
you travel you see these Muslims from
all over the world I mean one memory
I've got I actually traveled to Bosnia
for one of the funerals and every year
they have a funeral of the people have
been killed
and I was praying with 70,000 white
Muslims
you know the feeling was amazing you
know this this is when I had only been
Muslim for a few months and when I could
I seen this you know I really felt the
Islam ease is amazing truly in this
universe
everyone is fun subhanAllah so that's
what we opened the show talking about
Jesus Abraham Mohammed these were
messengers of gods you talk about the
specific message that Jesus brought the
injeel yes is that right yes talk about
this well the first the first point is
that as Muslims the other tells us no
cranny names some of the messages which
he sent throughout time so first of all
he mentions the stuff given to Prophet
Abraham peace be upon him he manages the
tourette's given to moosa moses he
mentions as the boar given to david and
also the injeel given to jesus peace
upon him so these were specific
revelations given to the prophets so
same again you had the torah so hoof
given to abraham torah given to moses
there's a ball given to david and the
injeel given to jesus peace be upon him
so these are specific revelations given
to the prophet this is communication
coming from now the creator becoming
part of his creation to deliver message
he's sending he's sending the message to
tell us what is the purpose of life how
to live our life and this is this is how
he communicates that makes sense that
makes our weekend we can comprehend
someone making something and you have a
instruction manual than the
representative right that goes and you
know defines everything for you you know
that's the messengers that's the
messengers yeah yeah so continue on now
the interesting point about this is when
we look at the Bible what is known to be
the Torah today he's actually speaking
about the Torah it's actually speaking
about an original revelation rather than
actually being the Torah itself they're
the same with the the Psalms if you look
at the sounds it's a collection of 150
poems which is written claim to be
written partly by David
David peacefull and other authors as
well
this is not what we believe as Muslims
we believe in a specific revelation
given to David well to stick on the
actual topic of the injeel which is the
one which I speak about in the book now
the the Gospels what we have today the
New Testament is actually a collection
of writings by various different authors
such as Matthew Mark Luke and John and
other writers like Paul now these these
scriptures are writings which came after
Jesus okay so the Christian scholars
accept that Matthew Mark Luke and John
and the other writings were writings
after Jesus okay well the interesting
part is that when we look at these
scriptures they're actually referring to
the original scripture given to Jesus
and this is a part of the topic of the
book so when we when the Christian opens
up the Bible and he sees Matthew Mark
Luke and John were these the disciples
of Jesus writing to be honest we don't
know who they was there on signed
documents we're not sure on the writers
of them but as I said the interesting
part is when we refer to them as
historical narrations which came after
Jesus they're speaking about a
revelation in the time of Jesus now if
we go to mark chapter 1 verse 14 and 15
he actually says Jesus came to Galilee
preaching the gospel of God okay
so Jesus was actually preaching the
gospel in his lifetime
so these later scriptures of Matthew
Mark Luke and John are speaking about a
gospel which Jesus was preaching in his
lifetime if we go to the next verse he's
actually a command of Jesus he says
repent and believe in the gospel okay so
here we have I mean if you hear the word
gospel you would automatically think of
the New Testament okay yeah and you
start to look into the New Testament for
for guidance or here the New Testament
of the books within the New Testament
are
referring to a gospel within the time of
Jesus
so this is it's a very important point
the most important part of this point is
when you go to the oldest scriptures of
the Bible now the oldest scriptures of
the Bible of sorry of the New Testament
are in Greek okay
now the oldest scriptures of the Bible
have something very significant which is
very important and if you remember the
point before when I was mentioning that
the Quran talks about a revelation given
to Jesus called the injeel now Sepang
Allah when we read the Bible so that the
scriptures of the New Testament in the
original farm in the oldest farm which
is the Greek it actually reads like this
and he says and the same verse reads
that when Jesus came to Galilee he was
preaching the injeel Ian of God and the
next verse is Jesus says repent and
believe in the in Jillian subhanAllah so
but when when you look at the
translations in the English they
translate to be good news or the gospel
and you can't see that this word is
being used it's a very important point
because the Christians won't know this
word in jillion actually say that this
word injeel IAM means good news yeah but
these other parts of the Bible which
refer to the ingenious have been more
than good news yeah let's take a break
and we come back with more here on the
Deen show I want you to imagine you wake
up and in front of you are a bunch of
guys running around kicking a ball no
goals no lines no rules what would you
think but is that your life surely every
sport has its goal every game has its
end it has its objective it has its
rules how about life how about our life
isn't there a goal to life isn't there a
purpose
an objective that we have to reach we
think so the Quran tells us that we
exist in order to worship God and
worshiping God means
knowing God as the Quran says when a
holic toll gender will insert allure
Leah Badoon worship though is not some
narrow small thing its wide its vast it
encompasses everything that the human
being does everything that you do
everything that you think everything
that you feel can be done thought said
felt in a way that is either pleasing or
displeasing to God the purpose of life
is to try and do everything in a way
that God loves and God is pleased with
that is your goal please subscribe to
the Dijon follow us on our official
Facebook and Twitter pages in the links
below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show with the author of
Jesus and the injeel so you were talking
about how in english it's translated
it's actually mentioned in the verbatim
word of the creator the Quran talks
about Jesus giving this injeel yes and
then in the what language is in in the
oldest scriptures of the new testament
in the greek is using the word in
Jillian and Julia and Julia now why are
they translating this to good news and
in in English well this is this is the
question yeah no this is the problem
with translations yeah this is actually
the miracle of Islam you know because of
the the colonies fully preserved in its
original language as it was revealed in
Arabic and he can't translate a message
from God you're going to lose the true
message lost in translation
exactly so when we when we come to the
the point of of translating this word in
Julian when we when we look at the New
Revised Standard Version of the Bible
for instance which which claims to go to
the the oldest Greek text which we have
we can see that the translations of the
word injeel e'en they've they've
translated it in whatever word they want
so if we go to mark for instance the
diverse which I mentioned before it
actually translates it as good news
so it actually reads Jesus came to
Galilee preaching the good news of God
well that's not unique because every
messenger came with good news
exactly here and he it says repent and
believe in the good news but in the same
translation the New Revised Standard
Version in in the same Bible with the
same word in jillion if we go to Paul's
writings within the Bible in
Thessalonians it translates the word
injeel e'en to be gospel so it for
instance it says those who did not obey
God those who did not obey they in
jillion you can see so so now the the
engine jillian is actually being
described as a law something more than
good news so many christians have
actually translated or they say the
meaning of in g Leon Ong Leon is good
news which we don't deny because as you
said the Quran tells us a lot else in
the Quran that he gave all the prophets
good news well specifically the injeel
there's a bore and these other
revelations were given to the prophets
and specifically the the injeel was
given as a message to prophet Jesus
peace be upon him so when we say good
news because going beyond just good news
because we believe as Muslims that the
Creator sent messengers to guide us he
now came with a warning yeah a warning
of the Hellfire and if you worship
another god besides God I can get you
into the Hellfire definitely and or if
you follow your desires and they gave
the good news of paradise kind of the
guidance the guidance so the good news
was their reward a paradise yeah
so that's interesting Quran preserves we
haven't its original what was given to
Jesus the NGO and Julian that's
obviously yeah you know the same same
book as well as we're saying later
describes these these later writings are
referring to something which Jesus had
in his lifetime called the injeel Ian
and they've they've commonly mistaken to
to say that this word here in Julian is
only good news but even the Bible itself
refers to the injili on being described
as a law being described as a message as
teachings so these are some of the
subjects which we point out in more
depth in the book
you
also mentioned that a lot of Muslims
make the mistake of saying that the the
translating also the the injeel or the
bible yes as being the the new testament
instead of bible being as one of these
books yeah i mean this this is a mistake
unfortunately which which even in the
translations of some of the english
translations of the Quran the mistake
has been made because we can see that
they translate in injeel to gospel and
and as a bore to psalms but the psalms
is a collection of poems by different
authors this is not there's a ball you
know and the gospel the Gospels of
Matthew Mark Luke and John are not
claiming to be revelation it's actually
referring to the revelation and even
within those scriptures it names is this
this to be in Julian so we shouldn't
really be translating these words we
should stick to the original that makes
sense so what would you advise Muslims
now say what you just said to whatever
the the creator says that he sent the
Torah we believe in a chart and it's
original in its original form yes okay
but you can't say that the Torah is the
Bible or the or the injeel is the Bible
no comment on this yeah I mean for
instance the Bible if we look into the
Old Testament it claims to have they
have something which they call the Torah
they have something which they call the
Psalms within the Old Testament and in
the New Testament we have various
different Gospels well these are not
they and they don't claim to be
revelations to the prophets you know as
I mentioned before that what is called
the Torah today is speaking about a
revelation given to Moses
what is the Psalms today he's speaking
about a revelation given to David and
what is the Gospels of today is also
speaking about the revelation given to
Jesus peace be upon him and these are
specific revelations now as far as the
Bible goes I mean many Muslims made the
mistake when they're conveying the
message and
did so with me as well by saying that we
believed in the original Bible or the
original gospel this is not actually
correct
we believe in the original revelations
given to the prophets and the names of
them are in the Quran okay so really
reiterate that so we believe in the
original the original revelations given
to the Prophet yes in their lifetime and
they are not writings by various
different authors huh yeah yeah that
makes sense it's very important point
because if you look at the six articles
of faith the six main articles of faith
which includes the belief in the books
let's go over those because somebody
right now is probably thinking okay they
maybe watch some shows oh how do I
become a Muslim this is what you have to
actually believe to become one who is
submitting to the will of the creator
and this is these six articles of faith
this is something that's been there you
know the this doesn't change this has
been there from the beginning right to
believe in these things so what are they
well the six main articles of faith to
believe in the Creator
one one one Christ leave one guy what is
his I believe in one guy but then they
add Holy Ghost and holy son it's the
correct the correct concept of the
crater which is there is one he selfs
assisting his eternal he doesn't have
children he's not a child and there's
nothing comparable to him you can't
imagine the crazy it's beyond your
comprehension yeah if someone says
what's the big deal I believe in one God
yeah I believe in one God but then you
know they say Trinity does that count in
no he doesn't
you have to believe in the correct
concepts of God as I said that you can't
imagine the Creator so if you're saying
that the human is a part of the Creator
then this is this is not God put it to
the test
yeah doesn't that go against also the
commandment in the Bible that says thou
shalt have no other gods except how you
yeah that the first commandment of the
Ten Commandments is that you Lord your
God is one well yeah
thou shalt have no gods in the heavens
and earth where to see see below just
verses the greater know the second one
is actually no partners to know no idols
no idols so this is covered in the
center Romans even if we go to John 17
verse 3 what is known as the declaration
of faith the Shahada is there he says
the the only way to return alive is to
believe in the only one true God and
Jesus Christ his son and this is what we
call the declaration of faith because in
Islam we have his only warranty God and
Muhammad peace be upon him is a final
messenger so it's the same declaration
today yes it's and Muhammad was sent as
the messenger yes Jesus and he was sent
as a messenger but not as a god exactly
makes sense right back to wrap it up
here on the Deen show is there a purpose
to our lives do we simply exist to make
a living
for were we meant for something greater
something more meaningful
I looked everywhere for answers and I
found Islam I started my journey
have you started yours
back here on the Dean show with John
Fontana the author of Jesus and the
injeel in the bible until it's
translated it's in the in in the semitic
languages it's it's called what well in
the in the oldest greats course it's
called when Jillian and Julia congenial
and Jillian that's the message that was
given from the crater yes to Jesus so
what are our brothers in humanity our
brothers now that obviously we're
brothers in humanity and in the Koran
the crater tells us that closest to us
are those Christians right so we really
want the best for them and what have
they said what has there been a response
to what you're saying well it's a mixed
response really some of the Christians
claim a still claim that the word injeel
Ian just means good news and although I
have I've actually shown them that it's
referred to as more than good news well
then with more research we can see that
even some of the Christian scholars in
the theological dictionary of the New
Testament it also states in Frederick
and Kittel that the injeel Ian appears
to be a long word which has been made up
to describe the New Testament you
understand so so even even the Christian
scholars are saying that this word
injeel Ian
he has no roots because many many of the
Christians they try to say that the word
injeel Ian comes from the root the
Hebrew word basura which in arabic is
Bushra which his glad tidings are good
news well in fact the the some of the
scholars of Christianity are saying that
this word in Julian is it's been it's
been made up to actually describe the
New Testament which we know can't be
true because the New Testament is saying
that Jesus in his lifetime
so it's New Testament which came after
Jesus is saying that Jesus in his
lifetime used this word and the audience
understood what this word was because he
was specifically proclaiming it as mark
says he was preaching the the in Julia
of God not the annealing of Matthew Mark
Luke and John
the in Julian of God and he also
commanded repents and
Eve in the in Jillian mm-hmm yeah the do
we find anywhere in in the in Jillian in
the message of Jesus that he called
people to worship himself alongside with
God we find it anywhere
and what about some of the evidence that
people people who use like you know like
the one for instance very famous that
nobody comes to the Father except
through me yes right so you you probably
know most of the the arguments that
people make for him being divine yeah so
what's your research now I mean what are
you got in the original message given to
Jesus in its original form that we no
longer have it it's not been preserved
this is why the Quran was revealed
because the Quran came as the final
revelation to mankind and the final
message but regarding did when we look
at the Bible there's many things that
agree with Islam and the Prophet peace
be upon him told us that we're not to
accept so sorry not to deny what they
say but we also not to accept it okay so
we can see that there's many
similarities in the Bible for instance
Jesus is described it where he says you
have to accept Jesus as well you have to
accept the God no one can come through
to the Father
no one can have eternal life except if
you believe in the one true God and
Jesus who he sent Jesus also described
himself within the Bible as a prophet
Mecca is described as a place of
pilgrimage Mecca and is well and this
well that's in the right it's in the
Bible he's described as a place of
pilgrimage Jesus praying with his head
on the floor these many similarities and
Allah tells in the cancer comes to
common ground with with the Christians
to show them that the similarities were
almost out of time two more points you
know I am the way the truth or the life
no one comes to the Father except
through me
what do I say about that well the the
true the true message of Jesus is it
listens what he says
it says no one can have eternal life
except if you believe in the messengers
you have to believe in all the
messengers which have come to humanity
yeah and the final messenger which is
Prophet Muhammad peace be and then I and
then earlier you talked
you mentioned the one guide that would a
Trinity just one God one yeah and then
the other five articles of faith what
are they
well you if before we leave we're almost
at the time so one God yeah believe in
believing one God believe in the
prophets belief in the books and this is
the correct concept of the books this is
this is how important this is sort of
the subjects which we're talking about
it's so important to understand even as
Muslims belief in the Day of Judgment a
belief in the unseen such as the angels
and also belief in divine decree so this
is it if someone but the main thing like
you said Prophet Abraham peace be upon
him he worshiped one God he was not
Jewish or Christian and the God which he
worshiped did not include Jesus they
didn't know it didn't include a Holy
Ghost I've just included the crater that
Jesus worship that we worship that
Muhammad call people to worship the one
God
yeah that's it worship the creator not
the Croatian work of people get the book
the book is on Jesus in the injeel accom
yeah so human you can download you can
download and you can alter online as
well thank you very much
we started with peace and we end with
the same greeting that Jesus once you
that's the greeting that he used peace
be with you thanks Melanie from awakened
song and yes it's the truth and you got
to hear it here it doesn't just
stimulate the mind doesn't it just
connect with your heart worship the
Creator not the creation and yes yes God
so loved the world yes he did that he
sent prophets and messengers with
guidance to guide humanity that's how he
shows his love he doesn't send a
unbelievable message that doesn't make
sense and all these concepts that are
just absurd and it's just you can't wrap
your mind around it but you can wrap
your mind around the worship of just the
one creator that's it everything else is
the creation we don't worship that which
you can touch and you make with your own
hands
no we worship the one who created the
Sun and the moon created you me the
seven seas the birds in the air the
fishing to see that one God that's the
only one that we worship and if you were
living there during the time of Jesus
you had to follow him yes he was the way
the truth and the light you couldn't
bypass him but never did he call
to worship himself alongside what God he
was subservient to God he called people
to worship God he was the teacher
illustrating how to do these acts of
worship the same way Muhammad peace be
upon him he was the last and final
messenger who was a brother to Jesus and
you will learn all of this and more
think of the verbatim Word of God the
car and 2806 6-2 Islam
follow us on Twitter like us on Facebook
so you can keep up with many of these
hot topics that we got on the Deen show
and many other interesting facts not
fiction that you will pick up on here
and there just really
enlighten you you'll be enlightened
that's right so we'll see you next time
inshallah God willing until then we end
with that greeting of peace peace be
unto you what are you gonna do with it
if somebody's been trying to deliver
something to you like we've been trying
to deliver the truth that there's only
one God you worship Him alone not his
creation
welcome to the bee show one of the most
exciting purpose of life talk shows in
the world since 2006 the theme show has
been working on clearing up the many
faults misconceptions about Islam and
Muslims and at the same time delivering
the simple message of the purpose of
life in a fun and exciting way I was at
a restaurant I was dressed like this and
a woman came to me she said are you a
rabbi we want you to develop a better
understanding about the pure Islam and
the real message that it teaches peace
submission surrender on obedience to
Almighty God
mom says love all mankind that's why
we're sharing this message because we
want the best for you and we want the
best for all mankind
we'll see you next time God willing on
the Deen show continue to tune in peace
be unto you please subscribe to the DCO
follow us on our official Facebook and
Twitter pages in